BETRAYAL OF THOSE SO CALLED
"JUDICIAL CONSERVATIVES" OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
BUT FIRST, DEMOCRATS DEVOUR OUR
CITIES, THAT’S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT’S "ANGLE."
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" TODAY
PUBLISHED A SEARING PIECE ABOUT
THE COMING EXODUS FROM URBAN
AMERICA.
IN JUST THREE MONTHS, IT HAS
BECOME CLEAR THAT MODERN URBAN
PROGRESSIVISM IS A POLITICALLY
INCOMPETENT INTELLECTUALLY
INCOHERENT.
THE UNHAPPY RESULT IS YOUNG
FAMILIES AND WELL-OFF RETIREES
LEAVE IS THAT THESE CITIES WILL
BE INCREASINGLY BECOMING MORE
DIVIDED BETWEEN UPSCALE
PROGRESSIVE SINGLES ABLE TO
AFFORD THE POLITICAL
INCOMPETENCE AND THE RESIDENTS
OF INTERCITY NEIGHBORHOODS THAT
WILL FALL FURTHER BEHIND.
IN MARCH WHEN THE COVID LOCKDOWN
BEGAN, WE SAW HOW QUICKLY LIFE
AND MOST BIG CITIES DETERIORATED
DETERIORATED.
LEFT-LEANING MAYORS PROLONGED
THEIR STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS WHEN
COMMON SENSE SCREAMS THAT DOING
SO WOULD ONLY CREATE TIDAL WAVES
OF MISERY.
SO WHEN THE SCHOOLS AND CHURCHES
AND COMMUNITY REC CENTER IS
CLOSED, THERE WAS LITTLE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE AND CITIES TO DO.
MANY OF THEM COULDN’T GO TO WORK
OR THEY HAD BEEN LAID OFF AND
WHAT HAPPENED THEN?
UNEMPLOYMENT SKYROCKETED AND THE
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN MAY
WAS THE HIGHEST IN MORE THAN A
DECADE AT 16.8%.
THE HORRIFIC KILLING OF GEORGE
FLOYD AND THE OUTRAGE THAT IT
TRIGGERED WAS LIKE A MATCH ON
DRY KINDLING WOOD THAT WAS DENT
DOUSED IN ROCKET FUEL.
POLITICAL ARSONISTS ENCOURAGE
CRIMINALS TO RAMPAGE THROUGH
CITIES AND SPREAD FEAR TO THE
SUBURBS.
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS WERE USED AS
COVER FOR BOTH ANTIFA AND BLM TO
PUSH A CORROSIVE
ANTI-LAW ENFORCEMENT NARRATIVE.
POLICE PRECINCTS WERE OVERRUN AS
MAYORS AND GOVERNORS SAT BY JUST
TWIDDLING THEIR THUMBS.
THESE URBAN SABOTEURS ARE SO
DESPERATE TO RID AMERICA OF
TRUMP, SO COMMITTED TO UPENDING
CAPITALISM, THEY’LL SACRIFICE
ANYONE AND ANYTHING ALONG THE
WAY.
IF SOME INNOCENT PEOPLE HAVE TO
DIE, IF SOME FAMILY-OWNED
BUSINESSES HAVE TO SUFFER, SO BE
IT.
IN A FEW MOMENTS WE WILL HEAR
HOW IF YOU ARE COPING.
THE SCENES I’M ABOUT TO SHOW YOU
ARE VERY DISTURBING AND THEY ALL
OCCURRED IN AMERICAN CITIES
WHERE RACIAL HATRED AND
ANTIPOLICE SENTIMENT IS BEING
ALLOWED TO FESTER AND GROW.
>> [BLEEP], [BLEEP].
>> [BLEEP]!
>> Laura: WHY DID THE OTHER
NETWORKS NOT RUN ANY OF THAT?
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING A MASSIVE
WAVE OF CRIME SWEEP ACROSS OUR
MAJOR CITIES.
NEW YORK CITY HAS SEEN THE
NUMBER OF MURDERS DOUBLE FROM
LAST YEAR’S FIGURES, FROM 19 TO
38, BURGLARIES AT 47%, CAR THEFT
60%.
THIS IS ALL THIS BY THE
LOCKDOWNS WHICH THE EXPERTS TOLD
US WOULD REDUCE CRIME.
OTHER CITIES ARE PLAGUED BY
VIOLENCE AS WELL.
L.A., THAT’S WHERE WE ARE.
POLICE REPORTING THAT MURDERS
ARE UP, GET THIS.
HOW MUCH?
250% JUST IN THE FIRST WEEK
OF JUNE.
AND AS RIOT SCRIP CHICAGO, THE
WINDY CITY SAW IT THE DEADLIEST
DAY IN 60 YEARS.
EIGHT PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN JUST
24 HOURS.
MOST OF THEM AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
MAJOR MEDIA OUTLETS DO NOT COVER
THE STOCKS.
WHY?
IF A COP TEASES SOMEONE WHO IS
RESISTING ARREST YOU’RE GOING TO
SEE EVERY CAMERA ANGLE.
WHY?
ARE DEMOCRATS AND MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA EXCUSING WANTON ACTS OF
VIOLENCE FOR SOME TO FURTHER OUR
PARTICULAR POLITICAL AGENDA?
OF COURSE THEY ARE.
HERE’S HOW THE BRIGHT MINDS AT
CNN RATIONALIZED RAYSHARD
BROOKS’ DECISION TO ATTACK
ATLANTA POLICE OFFICERS.
>> MR. BROOKS WAS KNOWN BY THEM
NOT TO HAVE A WEAPON OTHER THAN
THE TASER HE’D TAKEN FROM THEM.
>> A LOT OF NICETIES FOR A LONG
TIME.
WHAT ABOUT THE BENIGN OPTION OF,
THE GUY SAID HE’S GOING TO WALK
HOME, WHY NOT GIVE THEM THE
OPTION OF LETTING THEM LEAVE
THAT WAY?
>> Laura: HE WAS DRIVING
DRUNK, OKAY?
LOCAL AND STATE POLITICIANS IN
BOTH PARTIES ARE TOO AFRAID OR
TOO WEAK TO FACE THE TRUTH.
AMERICA HAS AN INTENSE SPIRITUAL
AND FAMILY PROBLEM.
NOT SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
POLICING.
FOR TOO LONG WE ALSO HAD AN
ECONOMIC SYSTEM THAT HELPED
MULTINATIONAL COMPANIES AT THE
EXPENSE OF WORKING PEOPLE.
SO INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THESE
VERY DIFFICULT PROBLEMS, THE
MEDIA, THEY WANT TO CONVINCE
KIDS THAT THE ENTIRE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM IS IN ITSELF
INHERENTLY ABUSIVE TOWARD ONE
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
NOW, YOU BET RACISM EXISTS IN
THE COUNTRY.
AND SO DOES CYNICISM.
THE TYPE OF CYNICISM THAT SAYS
THAT BLACK KIDS AND THEIR
FAMILIES DON’T DESERVE TO HAVE A
CHOICE IN EDUCATION AND THEY
DON’T DESERVE TO HAVE WHAT?
THEIR JOBS STAY HERE INSTEAD OF
BEING SHIPPED OVERSEAS?
WHAT THE LEFT IS PROPOSING AND
WHAT BIDEN IS PROMISING WOULD BE
DISASTROUS FOR ALL BUT, I’M
TELLING YOU, FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, THEY WOULD
SUFFER THE MOST.
THEIR ECONOMIC POLICY WOULD NOT
ONLY HAVE A JOB CREATION IN THE
UNITED STATES, IT WOULD RESTART
THE EFFORT TO SHIP JOBS
OFFSHORE.
SO ECONOMIC WAGE GROWTH WILL
STAGNATE.
OF COURSE, WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
CHINA WILL PROFIT, THOUGH.
NOW WEALTHY PEOPLE LIKE
MILLIONAIRES AND BILLIONAIRES
SPENDING BIDEN’S CAMPAIGN CAN
BENEFIT FROM ALL THOSE POLICIES.
AFTER ALL, MANY OF THEM ON THE
COMPANIES THAT WANT TO TAKE JOBS
FROM HERE AND SEND THEM OVER
THERE AND THEY WANT FOREIGNERS,
MORE OF THEM WHO WILL LOWER
WAGES THAN HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
AND BY THE WAY THOSE SAME RICH
PEOPLE CAN AVOID SOME OF THE
HARMFUL EFFECTS OF LEFT-WING
POLICIES BY DOING WHAT THEY’VE
DONE IN THE PAST, FLEEING THE
CITIES FOR THE SUBURBS.
THERE THEY WILL HAVE PROBABLY
PLENTY OF POLICE AND THERE THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO SEND THEIR KIDS
TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND WORK AT
DECENT JOBS.
ALL FROM THE COMFORT OF HOME.
BUT POOR PEOPLE OF ALL RACES,
ESPECIALLY THE ONES STUCK IN THE
CITIES, THEY WORK AT ESSENTIAL
JOBS AND THEY’LL PAY THE PRICE.
>> I COULD SEE THE GLASS
COMPLETELY JUST SHATTER.
>> AS HER HUSBAND RALPH WAS
TRYING TO CLEAN UP OUTSIDE, SHE
TURNED TO SEE HIM ON THE GROUND
IN FRONT OF A LARGE CROWD,
UNCONSCIOUS.
>> I STARTED TO SCREAM, I TRIED
TO WAKE HIM, HE WOULDN’T WAKE
BACK UP.
I TRIED TO CALL FOR THE POLICE,
NO ONE WAS PICKING UP.
>> Laura: NO ONE WAS PICKING
UP.
IT DOESN’T HAVE TO BE THIS WAY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SHOWN THAT
HE WILL FIGHT AND BEAT THE
BUSINESS LOBBIES WHO DON’T WANT
TO PAY AT DECENT WAGES TO
AMERICAN WORKERS.
UNLIKE BIDEN, HE WILL STAND UP
TO THE PRO-CHINA LOBBY AND KEEP
GOOD JOBS HERE AT HOME AND
UNLIKE BIDEN, HE WILL FIGHT
CRIME AND WORK TO KEEP OUR
CITIES SAFE AND VIBRANT FOR ALL.
UNLIKE BIDEN, HE WILL RESIST
EFFORTS TO DRAG AMERICA INTO
USELESS WARS.
JUST ASK JOHN BOLTON.
AND HIS PARTY STANDS WITH HIM.
THE REASON THE LEFT KEEPS
BRINGING UP AGE AND HISTORY IS
BECAUSE TODAY’S G.O.P. IS READY,
WILLING, AND EAGER TO WORK WITH
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
WE WANT TO EMPOWER THEM AND WE
WANT THEM TO MAKE A MAJOR
PART -- MAKE UP A MAJOR PART OF
THE G.O.P. COALITION.
ANY CLAIM TO THE CONTRARY IS A
LIE AND IT’S TOXIC AND WE WON’T
STAND FOR IT.
BUT DEMOCRATS HAVE NOTHING
SUBSTANTIVE TO OFFER WHICH IS
WHY THEY DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE
TO INSULT AFRICAN-AMERICANS LIKE
TIM SCOTT, WHO TAKES LEADERSHIP
ROLES IN THE G.O.P. AND TAKE
SOME VERY SERIOUSLY.
FOR THE LAST 60 YEARS, AMERICAN
LIBERALS HAVE PROMISED
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AT THEIR
POLICIES AND MAKE THINGS BETTER.
THEY WERE WRONG AND THEIR
POLICIES HAVE FAILED MISERABLY.
THAT’S WHY THE LEFT HAS TO
SPREAD HATRED AND DIVISION,
THAT’S WHY THEY’RE LYING ABOUT
THIS COUNTRY AND ITS HISTORY,
THEY HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE TO
OFFER TODAY.
THEIR ONLY HOPE IS TO PERSUADE
AMERICANS TO GIVE UP AND TURN ON
EACH OTHER.
>> IF YOU’VE OBSERVED AT CURRENT
VIOLATIONS OF THE SAVIOR AT HOME
ORDER, PLEASE CONTINUE TO LET US
KNOW IN THIS CAGE T MY CASE,
"SNITCHES GET REWARDS."
>> SOMETIMES MAKING THE
ENFORCEMENT IS THERE TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE.
>> EVERYONE WILL SAY, I’M NOT
RACIST.
GREAT, THAT’S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO DISMISS
THESE EFFORTS TO DIVIDE WHERE